it has been a lovely party with the
lionesses celebrating winning the euros
on stage in front of 7 000 people in the
square and plenty of onlookers trying to
peek through the railings outside
we were talking before all star we were
talking to faye white the most capped
england captain the longest serving
captain of the lionesses 97 to 2012 she
did that job and um
faye i i heard that you had a great
smile on your face when you were
watching watching all of that and i
don't know you must have felt part of
that journey as well and in fact jill
scott said
she's honored to have played with
anybody that's worn an england shirt and
she found to pay tribute to everybody
who'd gone before so that's the likes of
you and everybody else that must have
felt great
yeah of course it's a special moment
isn't it there's one person i would like
to
kind of say is about is steph holton how
she was the captain for a long time
after myself and recently up until
obviously leah took over and
if she arguably wasn't injured she would
have been part of this squad
and
i i text her to let her know that
so much of what we're seeing is down to
her too and it's players like that it's
all the players but obviously as a
captain they take the focus a little bit
more and she's been incredible
throughout her career ellen white is her
was a roommate she will have i'm sure
i've been talking to her and everything
and yes she would have missed out
physically been on the pitch on this
occasion but for years after my uh reign
as the captain she took over and for the
majority of it and did a fantastic job
so i have to single her out as well as
one of those players that should be
should be talked about and in the
bracket of these girls
yeah absolutely you are spot on there
and ellen white you just mentioned and
then she was one of the first to speak
this afternoon and she said
we've parted
but hopefully we've changed something
hopefully we've changed the game in this
country
do you think they have
how can you not how how could they
achieve what they have the pinnacle of
of a european football and how would you
not expect it to change it must do they
can't have done anything more um
to achieve this to look at these scenes
i mean i witnessed it seeing the germans
do it in 2009 go back to their country
and have this kind of
you know accolade this many more than
this many people come to out for them um
and to see it now happen in england and
to see this player this group of players
achieve it is is it has to make a
difference now
it's up there with the likes of justin
and his heel winning a well you know a
gold medal in the olympics the spotlight
she had on her at that time that's what
these girls have had to to deal with and
they've achieved the ultimate
yeah they absolutely have achieved the
ultimate and um
i don't know
they're living in a different world
perhaps to when you were the captain
even though it's a short time ago
because of social media they've now got
huge followings if you look at the
captain leah williamson she's got over
half a million followers this morning on
on instagram i mean that is that is a
very powerful
marketing tool isn't it and it it can't
be ignored anymore you can't expect
these girls to be earning 20 000 pounds
a year for what they've just done can
you
no no i mean that those figures on
social and in as far as what they're
earning i'm sure will now increase
more through sponsorships i hope and the
things that are coming into the game
like that obviously that we still need
people and fans to go out and support
the wsl matches week in week out get
behind your club go and find where the
games are the games need to be put in
bigger stadiums
clubs really have to step up and and
allow that to happen more than the wsl
um but yeah i mean it has to change
doesn't it you can't achieve this and
expect your elite top
women's footballers to
to be on low incomes anymore
[Music]
no absolutely and do you think the wsl
will have a greater appeal when it comes
back in september and is there is there
a big sort of marketing push to be done
on that so that you can sort of harness
and capture
the interest that there's been in these
euros and get all of those kids to their
local matches
yeah exactly that's what we need to do
it needs to be made easy for fans to
come and find the games travel to the
games and get their get bums and seats
really week in week out like i said and
watch world-class players and the unique
selling point is that
families young children can get up close
to these players they can get autographs
and photos after a game and i mean these
girls are going to walk down the street
and be iron dated now aren't they um
everyone knows who they are and rightly
so
i am not sure who is singing at the
moment but we did see lucy bronze
on the microphone and
in she was quite good isn't it she was
in shade she said they're feeling on top
of the world
but they want to get their hands on the
world cup
incredible they're already thinking
ahead to the next thing but that's the
sign of a champion i guess
yeah that's typical lucy and she this
will be up there as the best
achievement she's got to date but within
a few weeks she will be fully focused on
that world cup in a year's time
uh and i'm sure all of the girls will
serena will have a plan i'm sure
get qualified and then get there and you
know they'll be they have to go there
with a lot of confidence a lot of belief
after this